good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a lot of americans a lot
of people in the west are under
severe pressure right now to conform and
most of them do conform because they're
afraid
but it's interesting to see who doesn't
conform
who refuses to repeat the slogans who
stands up
piers morgan is one of those people not
sure you would have guessed that but
it's definitely true he lost his job
for telling what he believes is the
truth with a very long conversation with
him today on tucker carlson today
we're going to show you big chunks of
the interview in just a minute
but first we want to bring you up to
date on maybe the defining story of this
moment that hasn't gotten enough
attention
and that's the crisis on the border the
one in progress now the one that will
change this country for your
grandchildren profoundly
in the fall of 2018 not long before that
year's midterm elections donald trump
ordered a small group of active duty
soldiers to the american border with
mexico
congress had refused to build his long
promise wall and trump wanted to
highlight the severity of the illegal
immigration crisis which was going on
for decades
in some ways sending the troops was a
symbolic gesture only about 5 000
participated for perspective on how many
that is
that is far fewer about half the number
of troops that the democratic congress
sent to washington this winter
to protect itself from an imaginary q
anon threat
but for those with a vested interest in
open borders virtually everyone in dc
any military presence on our border was
just too much it was intolerable
official washington went berserk when he
did it deploying troops to our own
border for no national security reason
is one of the biggest scandals of his
presidency declared a senator from
hawaii called
brian schatz with what looked like
carefully simulated outrage
congressman philemon vela of texas who
was then the head
democrat on the subcommittee in charge
of border security
describe trump's tiny troop deployment
as a political ploy
designed to quote appease his white
nationalist supporters
it was racist of course it was the
so-called national security community
claimed to be every bit as upset as
their partners in the democratic party
it's a craven misuse of the us armed
forces for an
obvious political stunt said a former
national security council staffer
called kelly mags magsimon and that
turned out to be the right
thing to say for ambitious young players
in dc
less than three years later kelly
magsimon is now chief of staff to the
secretary of defense that would be the
political activist and defense
contractor lloyd austin
hot-headed congressman philemon vela
meanwhile the one who charged racism
has now ascended to vice chairmanship of
the dnc
so in washington there is always a real
payoff for those willing to repeat the
necessary slogans
and then the border how is the border
doing these days
remember the border well the military
our military is still involved in the
immigration crisis but not in the ways
that you might expect
american troops are now occupied serving
the needs not of americans
but of foreign nationals who have
flagrantly violated our laws
the biden administration is turning our
military bases into housing for illegal
aliens
if that sounds like a partisan attack
something we just made up
watch the president's own flak brag
about it
just in this past week we've taken steps
to bring a number of new facilities
online
from fort bliss where there are 5 000
beds to lachlan air force base where
there are 350 beds
san diego convention center fourteen
hundred beds these three sites alone
uh provided peak capacity an additional
sixty six thousand seven hundred and
fifty beds
so you break into our country and in
return we give you free housing and
medical care
pretty generous what's interesting is to
note who's not getting that treatment
last night more than half a million
americans spent the night in makeshift
shelters or on the streets they're
homeless
but the byte administration isn't even
considering the use of the us military
to help them
despite the fact that many are veterans
instead the administration is boasting
about all they're doing for the people
who have
demonstrated pure contempt for our
system
the system that some of us prefer and
would like to preserve
the press conference we just played a
clip from was ten days ago no one in the
media seems to have bothered to follow
up on that
fort bliss for example headquartered in
el paso texas won the largest army bases
on the planet how many illegal aliens
are now living
at fort bliss how many are there right
now
and the truth is we don't know we asked
authorities at fort bliss
point blank that question today but they
refused to tell us
instead they referred us to their bosses
in the biden administration to the
political commissars
america has no right to know how many
illegal aliens are living on our
military bases
and neither by the way do elected
members of congress who are charged with
overseeing all of this
but they can't know watch what happened
when one of them tried to find out
please give dignity to the people please
give them to the people so you worked
for the commissioner your senior advisor
you were hired two weeks ago and you're
instructed to ask
us to not have any pictures taken here
disrespectful because the political
leadership
at dhs does not want the american people
to know it please don't treat the people
you're right
and this is a dangerous place please
don't treat that and your policies
unfortunately are trying to hide them i
understand you were instructed
when 18 senators came down the people
give them
i respect them and i want to fix this
situation
the administration you're working for is
responsible for these conditions
please give dignity to the people
squeaks the women studies major from
wesleyan who's now overseeing all this
somehow
please respect the people she says
meaning of course
the foreign nationals whose interest the
biden administration is now serving
notice the total lack of respect for the
american people
the ones who deserve precise answers who
deserve
to see what's happening but don't get it
they can shut up and pay for it
officials at hhs to which we were
referred by fort bliss gave us no
numbers today when we asked
how many people are living at fort bliss
they did assure us however that quote
military personnel will not be staffing
this site or providing care for the
children end quote
that is a lie flat out it is not true it
is a
lie it's a crock we spoke to a person
with direct knowledge of this subject
this morning a relative of someone who
just deployed to fort bliss
to take care of the illegal aliens there
as of today the military has constructed
at least six
enormous tents at fort bliss each of
which will house approximately one
thousand illegal aliens
more tents are coming but because it
really is orwell at this point
military personnel have been instructed
and when you're instructed the military
you must
obey it's a crime not to they've been
told they are not allowed to take
photographs
of these tents those tents are now
national security secrets like missile
silos
why are they hiding this so they can lie
to the rest of us
some details have leaked out about
what's happening at the border here's
one the border patrol announced today
they've detained at least two people so
far whose names were on the federal
terror watch list
both men came from yemen you see their
pictures on the screen both just crossed
from mexico
into california so it's not just willing
workers it's not just fruit pickers who
are taking advantage of the total chaos
that joe biden has unleashed along our
border of course our mortal enemies are
taking advantage of it too and that
raises the question how many potential
terrorists have crossed the border
in the last three months and not been
caught that's a fair question
how many gang members have how many
rapists and murderers
you can say that you're not allowed to
ask that question but of course you are
if you live in this country you should
be asking that question it's not racist
to wonder
it's real how many pounds of fentanyl
have crossed over
how many more americans will die from
that drug the truth is we don't know the
answers to any of these questions
we do know that washington lies about
numbers constantly
you see it everywhere they tell us
inflation isn't real it's not happening
look around
yes it is happening it's entirely real
they tell us there are 11 million
foreign nationals living in the united
states when we know for a fact that the
real number is closer to three times
that
yet they keep lying 11 million
sources familiar with internal customs
and border protection data
have confirmed to fox news that officers
so far have encountered 171
000 illegal immigrants in the month of
march alone
in one month that's a 418 percent
increase from march of last year
but that does not represent the total of
people who crossed over
those are the ones who were caught those
are just the ones that we know about
the real number is higher much higher
how high is it
it's high enough to change this country
forever in every conceivable way
it's high enough to devalue your
political power as a voter
it's high enough to subvert democracy
itself it's high enough to make this
country a different place
but again we don't know the number why
is that we have
absolutely the right to know we should
demand to know
now